i want to go backwards for a second how
long did you know that tails was going
to be a part of the first movie
uh like did you know early on like how
much you were holding that secret in um
i had to hold the secret from the time i
did it till the film came out but i
didn't know
like it was sort of in their
post-production
portion of the program where they um
threw me in there so
yeah and funny enough when i went in i
didn't know that it was a credit scene
until i was finished with the session
and then somebody told her i was like no
way that's even cooler um so
yeah but i had to keep the secret for
about about six months
oh well that's actually not as bad as
not non-terrible yeah yeah some actors i
know have to hold it for years which is
like
hard
yeah i don't know how you do that um so
i'm so curious
what can you talk a little bit about the
differences of recording tales for say
like sonic the movie versus the video
games is it a like a radically different
process or is it pretty much the same
well it was similar this time because we
had to be by ourselves because of covid
so we were and for video games you off
you always record by yourself um so and
the biggest difference too for video
games is you have this script and it's
just a
pages and pages and pages of just your
lines um there's not a whole lot of
dialogue if there's dialogue they'll
tell you what it is but it's just it's
very different you're just like boom
boom boom boom boom line line line
online whereas with the film there is
dialogue there's circumstances there's
you know
seen things that are happening um so the
script looks very different um and then
as far as recording i did get to work
with ben a couple of times which was
wonderful and it's always great to be
able to work off your fellow actors um
but there was a lot of it that i did
have to do by myself um but i'm used to
that because i i do it all the time so
um
but i did love those moments when i did
get to work with ben it was fantastic
yeah it's so interesting to me how often
animated movies people are working alone
but i always would think that when
you're working opposite like ben and
you're recording sonic and tails you can
like riff off each other and just have
fun yeah 100 and he you know he's got
such an extensive improv background i
have a fair amount of improv background
myself which always helps with voiceover
and to get to do that with a skilled
improv or back and forth to have that
give and take is it's just magic it just
makes it so much so much better i think
there's a lot of cool stuff in this
movie what are you most excited for
sonic fans to see all of the easter eggs
all of the like i can't say anything
specific but my favorite team to work on
was the siberia scene that was so much
fun hilarious a blast but yeah i'm just
excited for them to see the relationship
to see where it's going where it's
headed how it evolves and all of the
action so much action in this movie yeah
and at times some of the action feels
like you're in a video game but like
it's in the movie if you know what i
mean yes 100
yeah totally and they grabbed so much
gold from you know they found places to
put all those things and made it make
sense and it does and it's
they really did such i'm so excited for
people to see this movie it's so good
it really is uh yeah obviously they've
already talked about doing sonic 3. i
know this is going to be a huge hit how
much have you been asking jeff so hey
what are you thinking about with sonic 3
what do you want to tell me
they have told me nothing
i know nothing i am jon snow um i i i
haven't been told anything other than
that it's in development so yeah i'm
very confident
yeah uh oh anyway i already got a wrap
i'm just gonna say congrats and uh good
luck with the rest of your speed dating
thank you so much have a great day